c'est une tradition bien établie à la
grande joie de tous ceux qui aiment les
spécialités régionales en matière de
gastronomie la frairie des petits
ventres de la rue de la boucherie à
limoges c'est reparti depuis la fin de
l'après midi une grande fête populaire
qui attire des milliers de personnes et
qui demande une certaine préparation et
oui c'est comme en cuisine et cela va de
soi car parmi ces milieux de visiteurs
ces milliers de visiteurs attendus agnès
molinier qui n'a pas pu résister au
plaisir de déguster des gogos les
grappes sont la grande nouveauté de
cette troisième favori des petits
ventres ce soit au rendez-vous date avec
du sang et dans lesquels on a injecté du
vert de poireau et ma foi c'est très bon
sinon la folie 1986 et avec la fuite
depuis 14 heures les premiers passants
se prennent dans la rue il revient peu
cette année il ya en plus une animation
les commerçants du quartier des halles
qui la cinquantaine d'états là je vous
proposes inondent des gourmandises bien
connu des habitués
ça marche très bien nous avons beaucoup
de membres ya plus de monde que
d'habitude
s comme presque pareil le pôle est ce là
c'est pareil je sois on verra on peut en
rire
qu'est ce qu'on vendait plus la pluie du
géo dès la mi temps les joues de
comédienne des anguilles et tout
l'éventail des ventes avec triple de
touba avait acheté n'ont pas encore tous
encore mais je pense que je connais pas
certaines choses mais je vais acheter
pour le goûter
il faut connaître vous venez pour manger
au moins j'ai ouïe pour moitié pour
boire vous venez pour manger aussi de
soi non non ne pas lasser costaud est ce
que vous étiez en général à des mariés
chercher de 10 jours de la fripe surtout
des jours une larme définitive vous avez
goûté
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose
tout est prêt pour une vraie fête
populaire avec la procession de notre
dame mais qui montre le défilé des codes
du barbichette et bien sûr la
traditionnelle corrida pédestre les 140
concurrents pour trois tours au total 7
km ils mangeront après bien sûr